i can't help but thinking that
it's this is the graveyard also for
great unfulfilled hopes because so much
could be achieved and this is the
this is the country where robert fisher
reached his peak
but it was not only his pick but it was
one of the most glorious moments in the
history of the game of chess
and it's it could have ended differently
so this is not for us to you know to
come up with hypothetical versions of
alternative history but uh
it's still very sad so it's it's as if
that's this
in this graveyard we could you know
feel that so many great hopes and
expectations have been buried without
being realized
so it's a it's all behind us so it's all
the controllers
so what is left is that you know uh
the unique contribution of robert james
fisher in the game of chess and i'm here
to pay these tributes
it's it's a huge sense of sadness
because
it's he's stopped playing [ __ ] at age
29.
it's just it's insane so it's just it's
how much can be done so how much could
be achieved you know just if not for
this
you know terrible tragedy that put him
away of the game of chess and
it's it again now after
everything is behind us you know all
these control verses and all
things that have been associated
unfortunately with fisher's name uh
what is left is just this this sadness
that he's gone
1972 and i also what i couldn't help
myself but thinking is i never met him
which is also quite
amazing so careful it was nine at age
and that nine
in 1972 when he won the title but still
you know
uh there were many opportunities
technically but unfortunately again
it didn't happen that's uh that's
something that of course
i will be missing 1972
definitely was one of the greatest
moments in the history of chess
i don't think chess ever reached such a
peak of popularity
as in 1972 and um
i could only only dream of of
using my abilities
to make sure that is the heritage of
1972 and this is the
uh the memories of fisher's great rise
uh will be somehow you know repeated in
the future
as i put in just in the book of
condolences that's
it's could only it could be a great
dream of
working together with with him to
promote the game of chess but
you know it did work out so but still
it's
this legend i'm sure will accompany us
in our quest for making game of chess
as popular as fisher wants
you